with anyone from history
Porefessional Randy the Macho Man Savage
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah you know it was great question you
know I'm RELIGIOUS about 18 and under
you know I'm you know I don't spend you
know I'm just I'm trying to think if an
individual under 18 has taught me
something I'm sure nothing pops to mind
but the whole the whole culture teaches
me a ton I mean you know it's very early
on musically you know as a matter fact
do a quick recall here of my episode
with baby Arielle who's now become
mainstream on Instagram and music and
she's just gonna be a beast 450 ish and
like most of them
I got like throw other peoples at school
like like you're exploring like
different styles of music that I had
never thought I would listen to just on
a regular basis and I've learned a lot
of words to the song yeah everyone's
like you know the word and I'm like on
the rim like oh yeah I know that for
musically I did that but sometimes I can
only know 15 seconds of the fact that I
have an askgaryvee with her four years
ago three years ago you know it's pretty
epic I learned a lot from under 18 to me
watching 14 to 18 is pretty much what I
most care about even going lower I mean
I you know watching how the slot you
know watching all the eight-year-old
girls become experts in making slime and
then reverse engineering it on how much
YouTube kids and a couple Instagram
accounts and and some snapchat Explorer
and just like you know really I I would
tell you that almost everything I
learned comes from that it's really
funny how obsessed I am with nine to 18
that is the culture to me what they like
you know oh cool like face tattoos are
good for them now cool like like they
will teach me pretty much everything and
it's interesting as you get older it's
interesting as I've gotten older I've
gotten more into the 14 to 18 not the
other way around and so it's taught me
that it's reinforced something I've
always known which is when you're 14 15
16 you want to establish your [ __ ] you
don't want your older brother stuff you
don't want your parents stuff and that
means you okay all of you will create
the next thing and if I can watch it and
understand it it'll give me insight into
where it's going and Gen Z for me is is
a sweet spot for me for vaynermedia and
and most of what I'm doing there's a lot
of strategies with that question there's
two ways to go about it one overall you
want to be a great number two or three I
think you need to figure out and spend
as much time with number ones and try to
see patterns in them and see if your
skill sets match to them
but if it's specific like if you work at
Wine Library or vaynermedia or you know
a great SAS company or a Tesla I don't
care what it is you need to reverse
engineer the individual like you need to
reverse engineer her you need to look at
the number one in your company the CEO
you need to say all right this is what
Sally's into so what she's good at this
what she's bad at this what she likes so
much she appreciates for example being a
good number two three four at
vaynermedia
pretty simple like I'm going to care if
you're capable of being the bigger
person empathy a leader that leads
positive energy like you're not like I
you can sell them trillion dollars in my
company like if you're a [ __ ] you're
gonna lose so that works with me a lot
of other people who are pandering to
short-term cash don't care if you're
nice at all if you can make a ton of
money that's what they need right now
because they're about to go public or
sell so you want to be able to be an
infrastructure for that so you have to
really reverse engineer the number one
and then you know number ones have a lot
of cliches you know they tend to be
entrepreneurial artistic like chaotic
like you know really you know to me
great number two three four or five very
often
are bringing unbelievable organization
skills capacity skills empathy you know
just a lot of those kind of things as
well so crossing T's and dotting eyes
which I'm incapable of and that's why I
got these maps but you know boy do I
need Marcus and and and the you know
James and Allen and Jeff of either
Andrea you know
Justine like that's what they have to do
dinner series that we're doing doing the
love speeches across the country and the
organization that success resources that
you know pick me up for all these talks
asked me to do some add-on events
strategy sessions and dinner sessions
and they've been a lot of fun you know
10 15 guys and gals in Houston you know
much small group in Florida I sort of
group here in Denver I'm enjoying them
you know I like people I like
interaction I think creates its content
potentially you know teams drove off in
the same but we'll see what happens
no excited about tonight got home at
like 1:00 a.m. last night from meetings
on how to get up at like 5:30 and then
flew all day and now I'm on East Coast
time in Denver so you know these are
some of the days you have to grind
through right like a big fan of six
seven eight hours of sleep sometimes you
do get four and sometimes done at the
same time that you got four you also
have to schlep across the country and
then stay out late it's like you know it
is where the [ __ ] it is so but we've got
to be on your on hey
my career is really quite more
predicated on psychology and intuition
and and respecting math completely but
not letting it dictate my behavior which
is what I think smart people allowed
like if I sat here if all you said to me
all of us are gonna cap out like why
like if a genie walked into Gary people
all of these men will only cap out the
easy answer is even bet on art to me to
me the reason people hit ceilings is
they let math dictate I couldn't I'll
explain it I'll explain it when you
think about everybody sitting here you
think about what the value you know even
the question is you're asking how much
are you making per employee people let
math math is incredible to a point and
then it becomes your enemy yeah the
thing that makes you successful is the
thing that then becomes your detriment
are you
[Music]
hello hello hello there's like in the
last couple of years to beat players in
a similar space like they're not do
anything spaced around teams but they're
doing things around all like bromide
finding the right people first Islands
talk tell the elephant's geek stuff yep
they've taken massive like [ __ ] like
yeah hundred million it yeah all these
budgets and they throwing it you know
yeah and it's like there's a whole new
arena now we're still very well known
but it's this pressure luck that we have
to we're gonna have to get into that
arena together from who pressure from
who
well cuz I'm going through babban
literally heard this argument me being
on this on the other side of that
pressure in my own company on the way to
the airport yesterday which is I'm not
gonna let you know and other media
publishers funding dictate my behavior
because it's a marathon I love when
people raise too much money it means
they're in trouble
and then I'm gonna ask you the RIT most
important question and this is why I'm
gonna win in my world from whom is my
employees my you know things of that
nature but there's nobody who has any
say when you say all this pressure I
heard you say it you it's self-funded
yes so how many partners if any do you
have good so then you're talking about
yourself to yourself is one person right
who's got the next loudest voice besides
your own voice in your head to yourself
well it's the same you know but it's not
the team right it's in if this is the
team in any team it's her then him like
in that team who's got the loudest voice
of all this pressure
there's your own competitive pressure
there's you know there's you which is
number one two and three
I'm just curious to give you the best
answer who number four is who number
five is because those become the
interesting questions because I think
what you're gonna realize is there isn't
this is what everybody goes through
wine.com raised a hundred seventy-one
million dollars when I launched
winelibrary.com for fifteen thousand and
then the [ __ ] world collapsed let me
promise you if I look at the PL and the
underbelly of the two companies that are
giving you pressure to do running your
business based on other people's
businesses is this quickest way to loose
running your business based on other
businesses behaviors especially in your
industry especially in your scenario is
the quickest way to go out of business I
don't know anything that any of my
competitors have ever done ever in like
[ __ ] 25 year career I'm aware you
can't be delusional you can't be
audacious I'm aware but I but them
opening a fourth location them raising a
hundred million dollars that doesn't
dictate me and I have pressure right now
from a lot of people to do things that
everybody else is doing but I'm like I'm
not building that like they're building
to a public offering or to a sale what
about marketing if they're on you guys
build a media company build build a
media company
let me explain yeah they're advertising
yeah if you can make it about you and
the stories of you if you can make about
yourself you can't be David Letterman by
advertising because it's David Letterman
you have to make it about you or your
team or your people or the stories or
the kids that were under privileged that
were affected by you you have to create
something that's ownable got it
they're building awareness they're gonna
get theirs brother but there's abundance
let's start with this market size your
model done right is unlimited revenue
good if you believe that everything
you're talking about is crazy stupid I'm
gonna help you if you believe that
you're not thinking about it properly
you're gonna get yours now if you got
your own competitive fire and you do the
cliche thing of like [ __ ] I did this
first and the only reason they're bigger
is because they just raised more money
I'm better than that see that's fine
that's human we all have that but that's
not a very good reason to start doing
things out of your comfort zone or out
of your belief or speeding up your
process for the sake of you don't like
how the narratives playing out right now
I didn't like wine.com all my friends
from a high school college being like oh
yeah that's gonna be who's gonna win huh
I didn't like that but like you know if
you're good enough you're gonna get
yours
you know you see where I'm going how are
you how are you hey mate how are you
buddy good to see you we do you like
this well yeah correct how are we doing
here
got to go on the stage here in Denver
[Music]
feeling pretty good feel ready confident
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna say something done I don't
want to say because I don't want to hurt
your feelings and I have no I don't know
you but I do want to say this I need to
hear this from me around this conference
it's important to me please understand
something that I'm fascinated by and I'm
hoping one person hears me and it's the
time they needed to hear it consuming my
content coming to conferences like this
reading more books debating about the
way the world should be being a
perfectionist debating complaining
dwelling all of it
excuses for not doing if you ask me what
I really want I want this to be the last
conference you ever go to I'm being dead
[ __ ] serious I I want you to
understand that it is very likely that
if you're sitting here you are trying to
find ways not to do
that's not everybody most but even if
one person here uses reading eighty
seven [ __ ] mindset and motivation
books and listening to forty four
[ __ ] podcasts and thirteen [ __ ]
blogs and coming to nine [ __ ] things
like this a year if even one person here
is doing that and by the way there's a
lot more than one person here doing that
it's yeah you're laughing because you
know it's [ __ ] true because you know
it's [ __ ] true right how do you do
these people need to read
it comes down to doing you can figure
out how to market your business to
accomplish all your [ __ ] goals in
life whether it has to build a pool in
your backyard or to buy the [ __ ] Jets
whatever is in between if you're
actually willing to put in the work you
know what I do
I [ __ ] work 15 hours a day I [ __ ]
write my captions on my Instagram I
reply your [ __ ] DMS I answer comments
I read my email it's [ __ ] work you
want the secret it's called work and by
the way do not get confused here you
have to work to match the ambition
coming out of your mouth this is not
about working 15 hours there you got
family you got other interests you knew
you but don't be a [ __ ] hypocrite
don't be full of [ __ ]
don't tell you're buying a [ __ ]
private jet when you're watching four
hours of YouTube videos a day cuz it's
work you have to figure out what you're
trying to achieve and what you want and
then you need to put in the work that
maps to that ambition and I know
somebody's sitting here to be like yeah
Gary you talk about hard work but I work
I work smart too and hard now what Nick
the current scientifical mathematical
odds of being born are 400 trillion to 1
like your your mom might have got up and
got another glass of wine
400 trillion to one you're more likely
to win the Mega Millions nine times in
your life then you are to even have a
life I like data that's data we've got
one life do something about it thank you
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
hello me can you Terry
thank you so much this is a pleasure
let's go really well do you're out here
nope babban thank you
okay Gary my name is win wall yeah win
nice to meet you
if you will face to it do you were
babban but goodie like scone by D Rock
more you could make such a great piece
of content you know like you got to take
ownership of it yeah you gotta let go
the other way you know that's how you
win it's a mile you got to make a video
of your mom call it like literally put
your mom on speaker and it's like she
owes mom it's like okay mom she's like
hey so how are you doing do you rock you
guys it's patience your business is
[ __ ] a second old bro like like I
don't even want to ever talk to you
again for another six years and then and
that I can't wait but I'm telling you
you're gonna be seeing me soon is the
biggest reason I don't think I'm gonna
be seeing you soon and I'm not trying to
rather I love you the altoon thing we're
friends already but
I need everybody to really wrap their
[ __ ] head around this I'm gonna make
it very clear I on my children's health
I believe I'm just starting on my
children's health
I am so early in the process it will
make your head spin it cool nice things
are happening I understand from where
I'm going what I'm actually up to I'm in
the first inning being seen soon this
and that even that question is
completely inappropriate coming from
love this early on like a lot more
organic like a lot more like 20 hours a
day if you want it that bad because the
alternatives you're gonna go work
somewhere right so to me it's like
people like man but like when I tell
them 18 hours of community management
huh searching hashtags putting out
content more videos I've put out 147
pieces of content a week you know but
like I did way more tweets when it was
just me and my phone and wasn't the
[ __ ] Twitter was even mobile at 4:00
it was a [ __ ] a desktop and like like
the answer is a lot more my biggest
piece of advice is that you think in ten
and twenty and thirty year terms for
real not just in a tweet not just to be
here right now your actions let me just
say one more time because I need
somebody I know I need somebody to hear
and hear from the day I started running
that wine business at 22 years old so I
was 13 or 12 years I worked 15 hours a
day six or seven days a week in a liquor
store 12 years in a row
15 hours a day in a liquor store 15
hours a day had no social life never
paid myself over 150,000 a year left at
34 to start with AJ vaynermedia had 0%
ownership of Wine Library which means I
had no collateral to get a loan or any
leverage with a bank for anything in
business and had no money in my bank
account I was 34 I'd already built a 60
million dollar business not for myself
that's called patience so when I spit it
to you I'm not coming from hypocrisy or
a high horse I live it I'm leaving
millions of dollars on the table every
year for patients the answers a lot more
[Music]
on the way to Chicago got some big
vaynermedia stuff there tomorrow you try
to meet up somebody tonight
that would make the internet very
extended
babban was tremendous continues to
separate himself from d-roc in so many
ways
Denver's energy was tremendous great
audience a lot about patience just you
know
reinforcing your beliefs executing on
your beliefs like the dead silent the
last 14 minutes just replying the people
on Twitter answering business questions
putting in the work putting in the work
you know so many people are looking for
the answer
the answers are super basic they just
don't want to hear the truth
so
you can read about and watch about it
and come up with excuses why somebody
else got it
this is an inside game nobody's taking
your money nobody else's business
it's doing anything to you you're doing
it to yourself and
either you're putting in the work smart
strategic work or you're not the reason
you're not isn't because you're lazy
it's because you're not passionate or
you don't see it where you've lost your
way or something else is bothering you
and so
I'm just trying to just try to force
people to understand how good it is how
much opportunity there is I want this so
badly for you I want it so badly for you
because I've gotten mine
so what happens after you've been
fulfilled
you start overflowing and you want
people to pick up on it
[Music]
the greatest year had ever be alive
right now
I don't give a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] TV
tells
[Music]